what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and Marvel Studios
released so much at San Diego Comic-Con
we had a lot of announcements for new
movies including two new Avengers movies
a new Captain America the Thunderbolts a
daredevil series that is going to be 18
episodes long but out of all of that we
did not get any sort of announcement for
the X-Men and this was pretty
disappointing for a lot of fans however
we do have Disney's d23 day coming up in
a couple of months so there is always
hope that they're saving that big reveal
for d23 however today we might have a
pretty good idea of when the mutants
X-Men might actually be hitting the MCU
and we also might have an idea of one of
the actors that could be playing an
X-Men this actor has spoken up openly
and publicly about meeting with Marvel
Studios and talking about playing a
character for the X-Men however there
could be some good news and bad news
that comes with that as well as when the
X-Men are going to actually hit the MCU
but I will break down everything that
you need to know in this video now right
away let's talk about a report that has
come out recently stating that Marvel
Studios cannot even do the X-Men in the
MCU until 2025 which sounds crazy now
technically they can however there's a
Twist they would have to use some of the
old actors and characters from the fox
X-Men franchise which obviously they
don't really want to do unless it's in
some type of a Multiverse Manner and I
know this may freak some people out but
don't worry everything goes okay I'll
explain why but first let's talk about
this report according to Devin faraki
former editor-in-chief of birth movies
death and current co-host of Marvel
Vision 20th century Fox's contractual
obligations to actors in The X-Men
franchise have carried over to Disney
slash Marvel and are in effect until
2025. this means Marvel cannot recast
announce or enter production on a film
that includes roles held by some if not
all of the most recent principal actors
in The Fox X-Men in a franchise Deadpool
3 and Xavier in doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness are exempt because
they are the original actors playing the
roles now after this report came out the
Illuminati came out and they said that
they did some digging and they
discovered that actors are not the only
ones that have a standing contract tying
them to the X-Men according to their
sources Marvel is holding off on the
X-Men because the producers of Fox's
X-Men films are still attached via
contract as well and now it's starting
to make sense that Disney and Marvel
would not want to do the X-Men soon
because they want to recast all of these
characters but they also don't want any
of Fox's people involved so basically
it's not the concern of having old
actors come back and play their roles of
the X-Men it's really getting away from
Fox and getting away from the people who
made the fox X-Men movies which if you
have seen most of the recent Fox X-Men
movies you definitely understand also
not to mention these people at Fox have
no connection to the MCU whatsoever they
have had no involvement in creating
anything in the MCU so they're really
not in the know and they're really kind
of just not a part of the family
unfortunately now this might seem like
some pretty bad news however I don't
think this has stopped Marvel Studios
from trying to cast who they actually
want because if this is true this just
means that they can't make a movie until
2025 it doesn't mean that they can't
start preparing for the movie to happen
in 2025 and also keep in mind yes we are
hearing about this but nobody ever truly
knows 100 what is really happening
contractually behind the scenes with
some studios like to this day we still
don't know what the actual contract
between Sony and Disney slash Marvel is
with Spider-Man we have an idea but we
don't fully know and it has been
revealed recently that Taran egerton has
actually met with Marvel Studios about
plane and X-Men now fans have been fan
casting him to play the new Wolverine
for years now now he's a phenomenal
actor he's got a lot of range from
Kingsman to Eddie the eagle to when he
played Elton John amazing actor and I
actually do you think that he would be a
very good Wolverine however he actually
met with Marvel Studios about playing
Cyclops and he actually revealed this
himself take a look at this clip
collapsed
that too that yeah I don't mind saying
that was that was a real thing there was
a real conversation and
um
to be honest I've never said this
actually to be honest the reason that
conversation never went any further
is because I I don't I didn't want to I
didn't want to play a character for a
potential of a series of movies okay
where you don't see my eyes for me that
that's I I didn't I felt instinctively
creatively that that like the eyes of
the windows to the soul I don't know how
I would find that challenging and I just
didn't find it an intriguing Prospect so
if it's not that they ever offered it to
me but there was a conversation a real
conversation that never went any further
wow I respect so Taryn egerton had talks
with Marvel Studios about playing
Cyclops now right away I just want to
say that just because he kind of turned
down the role of Cyclops does not mean
that he may not play in X-Men and still
could even Possibly play Wolverine and
he does say more about meeting with
Marvel Studios and what's really
interesting is that he says he met with
Marvel Studios four years ago which is
actually a really good sign because if
Marvel Studios can't make movies about
the X-Men or mutants until 2025 then
then why would they be meeting with
actors in 2018 perhaps they're just
preparing way in advance but here's what
Taran egerton had to say about possibly
playing Wolverine he says I made the
mistake of saying that I had a general
meeting at Marvel Studios around four
years ago which is true but it got kind
of Spun and twisted into this thing so
I'm now at a point where because look
I've always said I don't know if I'm the
right guy to play that part I was with
Hugh Jackman yesterday briefly who
obviously played the role originally
were such different Vibes I don't know
if I would be the right person to follow
him but I've always said I would be open
to it but at the moment there's no truth
other than the fan casting thing which
goes kind of crazy every time I mention
it but you know who knows however he
does go on to say that he would love to
be in the MCU listen to this he says so
the reality is that there's been a lot
of fan casting for it and I took a
general meeting with Marvel Studios as
president Kevin feige about 4 four years
ago where I said it would be I love the
movies I would love to do something and
he said it would be great if we could
find something and Taran egerton says I
walked away and haven't spoken to him
since I checked my emails every five
minutes but there's no there was never
in fact there was a character that I
mentioned in that meeting but it wasn't
that one so that puts it into some
perspective so there's no truth no
reality to it but you know I'd love to
be a part I'm a fan of those movies now
the character that he mentioned in that
meeting was of course Cyclops which he
turned down because he didn't want his
eyes to be covered the whole time and
there is still a chance that he could
play Wolverine because yes Hugh Jackman
was iconic and yes they are a little bit
different than each other but you can't
simply look to replace Hugh Jackman
meaning you can't get somebody to try
and be the exact same Wolverine it just
won't work because everybody will always
compare him to Hugh Jackman The
Wolverine that we get has to be
different and if that's what Marvel
Studios decides they want to go with it
could would be Taryn and who knows if
he's actually telling the truth here of
course he's not going to come out and
say oh yeah totally talk to Kevin feige
I'm going to be Wolverine it's going to
be fantastic the movie's coming in late
2025. I wish you could say that but
there's absolutely no way so he could
have already actually signed with Marvel
Studios to play some X-Men maybe even
Wolverine we won't know until the
official cast is announced now like I
said if these contractual obligations
are true and Marvel can't make a movie
until 2025 it doesn't mean that they
can't start working on the cast working
on the script working on the movie in
general in fact Marvel's Phase 6 slate
has five movie slots or Disney plus
slots that don't have a title to them
yet one of these could indeed be the
X-Men and the rest of Phase 5 is already
filled anyways so even if it can't come
out until 2025 it's really not that much
longer than we would have had to wait
because it would have been late 2024 at
the earliest so if you've heard this
report don't worry that doesn't really
affect the X-Men that much it only might
mean the X-Men might actually come after
Secret Wars and they would start off our
new saga it could be the mutant Saga
we'll have to wait and see but maybe
we'll see Taran eagerton playing an
X-Men possibly even Wolverine let me
know what you think about this would you
like him to play Wolverine or do you see
him playing somebody else let me know in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news for live updates you can follow me
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof